we did adopt the new rules on the
package travel to meet the requirements
of the Internet age where the ministers
also adopted the conclusions on the
digital transformation of European
industry and we also agreed on the
general approach and the single member
private limited liability companies the
council express its support to the
recent trialogue agreement on the trade
market pocket this reform really meets
the main objective of the Commission
proposals from 2013 will have system
more modern more efficient and more
accessible for the company's the
foundation of a modern and innovative
economic system in Europe requires the
development of the European research
area and the European Digital Agenda
therefore today we adapted three sets of
council conclusions the first two were
on the development on European research
area Erin short and the third set of
conclusions was on the role of research
and innovation in the new digital agenda
for europe at the European level we've
done the European research area map and
roadmap for the future but now we need
countries to implement and to come up
with those road maps so we agreed that
we would by mid 20 16 by jun 20 16 to
extra to have a big conference where all
the countries will present their road
maps